[Musique]
c'est pas toi mais moi ça va pas du tout
entre matin je me lève tôt le soir où je
me couche tard je ne fait que courir les
journées sont trop rythmé c'est trop à
fond et franchement elles sont trop
courtes entre la nourriture trop grasse
qu'on mange et le manque d'exercice
rien ne va plus les bourrelets apparaît
souvient gros et avec le temps qui passe
c'est de pire en pire
et là franchement je peux le dire mon
corps n'en peut plus il réclame du sport
il réclame d'en faire un peu plus et
d'arrêter de me gaver seulement le
manque de motivation les journées trop
courtes font qu'en règle générale je
n'ai pas assez de sport et je sais qu'on
est trop nombreux dans ce cas là des
hommes comme des chinois hans ont de
vraies sources d'inspiration à 80 ans il
a un physique incroyable que beaucoup
d'hommes rêverait d'avoir on prend pas
le temps de s'occuper de nous on se rend
pas compte mais temps passe et on
devient des grands mollusques tout gras
regarde à 20 ans comment on était ça
c'est le corno 20 ans je me suis
bienvenue dans la trentaine et si on
fait un gars et bienvenue à 40 ans donc
en réalité si on fait pas gaffe on
finira tous gros comme ça à faire tenir
notre bière sur notre ventre et ça c'est
pas possible je vais te donner quelques
astuces à appliquer dès aujourd'hui pour
se reprendre en main se ressaisir et
perdre tout ce gr parce qu'en réalité
c'est un combat tous les jours si tu
veux que les femmes te regarde un petit
peu si tu veux pas être le moche de
service et le gros service il va falloir
se ressaisir surtout quand on sait que
ce que regardent les femmes en premier
c'est ça si tu ne restes et gaulle et si
tu veux entretenir
il faut faire plus plus tu vieillis et
plus c'est dur donc plus tu prends de
l'âge et plus il faut en faire donc je
vais te montrer comment bouger option
pour avoir un bon piont pour être gaulle
et pour ta femme te regardes tu la perds
pas et pour que tu sois plus épanouie
quelques exercices simples à faire à la
maison tu verras rien de plus facile
j'ai défilé 10 exercices de base
hyper simple qu'il faut que tu fasses
absolument tous les jours essaye de les
faire au moins le matin si tu peux deux
fois par jour ça serait génial
premièrement tu te fais des pompes tu te
fais quatre séries de 10 temps fait
disent tu récupères pendant 15 à 20
secondes
[Musique]
ça tu peux le faire n'importe où on situ
fargues et ashkenazes de face une minute
deux faces fut un peu de gainage de
situer la sematra servir les fesses
gainage de côté tu te fais 30 secondes
de chaque côté puis au final ça fait du
bien
ensuite il fait des sauts sur place
bright jambes le long du corps et
ensuite tu sautes tu montres tes bras et
écarte les jambes des abdos tu te fais
une série de trente abdou tu peux l'y
fragmenté en dise tu te fais dix ados 10
secondes 15 secondes de pause 10 abdou
15 secondes 10 abdou 15 secondes tu
fragmente
[Musique]
e
faut prendre du temps pour faire du
sport même s'il en a pas beaucoup
il faut penser à soi montent et
descendent d'une chaise ça va vraiment
aider au niveau des jambes surtout si tu
fais pas beaucoup d'erreurs si c'est que
tu prends l'ascenseur
des pompes en tout dans une chaise de
dos
cours sur place pendant environ 15
secondes
tu descends sur tes jambes toutes mes
droits tu descends dans la jambe gauche
tu remontes tu te mets droit tu la sens
la jambe droite tu en fais une quinzaine
environ
tu finis par des pompes les bras levés
tu fais des pompes tu remontes tu lève
le bras droit tu fais des pompes tu
remontes eu lève le bras gauche
tu me fais des séries aussi tu m'en fais
30 et tu me fais des séries de 10 avec
un break toutes les 15 secondes
[Musique]
au final tu vois tout ça c'est pas très
compliqué mais il faut absolument que tu
le couple avec d'autres choses au
quotidien
tu peux pas te contenter de faire du
sport fais attention à ton alimentation
effet un maximum d'efforts par jour par
exemple au travail dès que tu as une
pause
lève toi dès que tu prends une
pause-café fait des étirements dect et
au téléphone lève toi et marche reste
pas statique toute la journée et celle
de moins prendre la voiture
geert omloop plus loin pour marcher un
petit peu plus si tu prends les
transports en commun reste debout au
maximum de dents prend pas l'ascenseur
prend les escaliers boycottent les
escalators si tu dois aller prendre
montrent les escalators en marchant
quand tu pars faire tes courses garde
toi le plus loin possible
si tu transportes un sac un peu lourd et
c'est de fléchir un peu les gens pour
faire travailler des muscles soit
paraître comme un pic et va pas au drive
va dans les magasins marche marche
marche chez toi quand tu fais du ménage
va plus vite déjà tu te feras moins cher
en ménage sert à beaucoup plus vite et
ça c'est un vrai gain de temps et puis
surtout cette muscle aura ça donnera une
dynamique quand tu passe l'aspirateur ne
dépense pas fléchir les jambes savate
musclé et en plus ça va préserver ton
dos 3 l'habitude de tout faire toi même
ne délègue pas quand tu fais la
vaisselle fléchit un peu les jambes se
cambre pas pareil quand tu cuisines
tu vois c'est un ensemble de choses
qu'il faut faire c'est se déplacer
marché faire attention évitez d'être
feignant on est de plus en plus
feignants et ça ça fait apparaître les
bourrelets si tu veux bien vieillir si
tu veux être meilleur si tu veux
retrouver le corte 20 ans il va falloir
sortir les doigts et bouger le cul tu
vois en réalité c'est super simple je
vais ajouter des liens dans la
description de chaîne youtube est allé
voir deux chaînes youtube qui sont
spécialisés dans le sport si tu veux
aller plus loin tu auras encore plus de
conseils en plus des bonnes pratiques
pour ma part je te donne rendez vous
très bientôt abonne toi mais moins
commentaires pour me dire si ce type
d'exercice tu conviens ou si
éventuellement tu voudras autre chose si
tu essayé moi je vais faire à partir
d'aujourd'hui je veux le faire tous les
jours et on fera un petit point dans
quelques temps tu me diras ce que tu en
penses
en attendant en porte toi bien fais
attention tu perds ce gr tu verras tu
sera meilleure et tu seras mieux dans sa
peau
alia de mon lapin